[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
June 8th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
Rising interest rates means higher
Returns on bond Investments but buying
bonds isn't as easy as buying stocks so
one investment firm has introduced an
automated tool to focus on bonds wsj
personal finance reporter Amani movies
joins me to discuss how it could benefit
investors so Amani what is Robo
investing and what does it allow an
investor to do so a robo advisor works
just like a regular financial advisor
except for is an algorithm so you make a
deposit you give them your money and
then they invest it for you in a mix of
usually Equity is in fixed income to
create a balanced portfolio that's
automatically rebalanced help us for a
moment here with bonds 101 how is a bond
different from a stock so when you're
buying a stock you're buying a piece of
a company when you're buying a bond
you're buying that company's debt so
everyone's talking about Rising interest
rates and really what that means at its
core is that borrowing is getting more
expensive so if you as a bondholder are
funding either a company's debt or the
government's debt that means you get
paid more and another way that they're
different is that the value of stocks go
up and down with the market but as long
as you hold your bond to maturity those
returns are going to be a lot more
consistent and predictable now we've
seen investment companies launch Robo
tools for investing in stocks why did
wealthfront decide to launch this for
bonds initially Robo advisors were a way
to automate investing and they followed
traditional portfolio Theory saying that
the best way to invest is to have a
diversified portfolio of stocks and
bonds but as the Federal Reserve has
been raising interest rates interest in
bond investing has surged and who's this
program geared towards most Robo
advisors are targeted towards younger
investors meaning in investors under 40
which makes this product particularly
exciting because for a lot of those
investors this is the first time that
they're seeing interest rates high
enough to make bond investing worthwhile
and a reasonable alternative compared to
the stock market if you think about it
interest rates have been close to zero
since 2008 the last financial crisis and
just when they started to pick up we got
hit with a pandemic which sent interest
rates close to zero again so why has
Robo investing become so popular I think
Robo investing has become really popular
because of its ease of use it's a really
good way to set and forget your
Investments so when you're working with
a human financial advisor typically they
rebalance your portfolio every few
months but by using a robo advisor
that's happening automatically all of
the time all right so how does this work
if somebody wants to invest in bonds
using this Robo advisor what would they
do the first step when you open an
account is to answer a short
questionnaire they're going to ask you
questions like how old you are what your
income is and what state you live in
because that determines the tax
considerations that impact you next you
just fund the account and the algorithm
automatically chooses a mixture of
corporate and Government Bond ETFs to
invest in it's paying attention to the
market and seeing when the value of
Investments rise and fall it's paying
attention to different tax
considerations and it's making sure that
the value of your portfolio stays
relatively consistent to the yield
that's promised and that it's minimizing
any potential tax burden I talked to one
wealthfront client who started playing
with investing right after he got out of
college kind of right after the last
financial crisis but quickly realized
that while he was seeing a lot of gains
from Trading stocks and doing things on
his own he was also paying a lot of
taxes so one of the cool things about a
robo advisor is that they do something
that's called tax loss harvesting which
is automatically rebalancing your
portfolio and selling when there are
certain losses to offset any capital
gains taxes that you may have to pay as
an investor you know for the investor
who would have time to do that all day
you're right it's a full-time job that's
why it's easier for the algorithm to do
it or if you can afford it using a human
financial advisor so how is this bonds
Robo advisory account different from a
robo account that you would have with
stocks so wealthbunch's marketing list
as a safer less risky alternative to its
traditional investing account it
launched with an advertised yield of
over five percent Which is higher than
you can get from high yield savings and
a lot of CDs right now so by putting
money into the bond account you're
guaranteeing that you're going to get
that rate over the short term and it's a
good place to park money that you want
to save for short-term goals like maybe
a down payment or buying a car we talk a
lot in the show about people needing to
save more they're marketing this as
another saving solution they also have a
cash account but the yield on this Bond
investing account is a little bit more
aggressive when Robo stock accounts came
onto the scene a couple of years ago
more investment companies introduce them
do you expect more investment companies
to introduce similar things to
wealthfront definitely I think fintech
has done a really good job of bringing
technology to make investing in the
stock market very simple and very
seamless and now that you're seeing a
renewed interest in bond investing I
expect companies to invest in making
Bond investing a similarly easy process
that's Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Amani movies and that's
your money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign